what do you typically look for in women
when you're trying to vet them for
you know hey listen you know you're an
athlete you made a lot of money you're a
good-looking guy you're tall like you
take off every box that chicks are
looking for generally speaking
so what do you look for it's kind of
hard to know what they're really after
so you really really got to be careful
does she have a strong family background
does she have a good father to me that's
really huge do you see a lot of daddy
issues in
southern california 60 of women i've
taken out have had daddy issues there's
got to be a level of confidence there
that she has
and not boss confidence i can't
stand that
boss girl hashtag boss girl buddy come
on sign up for that man
don't you want to come home to a
disagreeable woman after a hard day's
work bro
right she's got to have some kind of
brains on her she's got to have some
kind of
dreams for herself to where she's not
latching on to me
24 7 texting me 10 times a day
i need space i'm an independent guy and
i don't need you around all the time